and can you talk a little bit more about
why girls nights out are disrespectful
because just devil's advocate here i
mean it's not like you're going to hook
up you're just going to have a good time
with your girls
yeah you which obviously leads to
drinking
um it leads to interacting with men you
don't know
um it leads to making poor decisions um
you know
if you're out there dancing with your
friends yeah you could just be dancing
with your friends next time you know
you've got a strange guy who's bumping
up behind you you know and let's just
take a flash moment of any of these
scenes of these girls nights out and
just like just take a picture of it and
if your husband saw that or your
significant other saw that what would
they think
and a lot of women don't think about
how they look and how they're presenting
themselves to the world and if you
present yourself to the world as a
single person the world will treat you
as such or they don't care right
yeah a lot of times they just don't care
no i just energetic
do you think so one observation that
i've had is i think a lot of times girls
act like this because they married their
second choice
oh yeah
do you feel like that's something that
you've seen
oh yeah 100 man um
the difference between and it's weird
because a lot of women marry who they
believe is their first choice and then
over the years their first choice
becomes their second choice so they
marry the guy they think is the highest
value guy out there but then they are
handpicked by these men these husbands
are handpicked by their wives they're
handpicked by movies television
commercials netflix etc etc and then
when guys like me come out and say hey
listen don't be afraid to don't be
afraid to raise your voice to your woman
oh my god that's misogynistic and
borderline illegal and blah blah blah
then when i tell people listen man i
don't commit i do not commit to women
who go to clubs or bars oh my god it's
just for girls nights out
okay that's fine but what what this what
this really comes down to is the reason
why these men turn into their wives
their their wives second and sometimes
even third choice depending upon the
number of times they cheat is because
men are
legally castrated we we are
our society shames a man's ability and
instinct to protect a woman from herself
to protect his relationship there's no
reason a man should be okay with his
wife or his girlfriend going to bars or
clubs even if nothing happens the fact
of the matter is is that bars and clubs
putting yourself or a woman a lot of
people say if a woman doesn't if a woman
loves you she will not cheat that's
incorrect if a woman loves you she will
never put herself in position to cheat
she will never put herself in an
environment where infidelity is
uh
uh can happen more times than not social
media is a breeding ground for
infidelity bars clubs traveling alone
girls nights out girls trips and there
are so many women i don't know what the
percentages are but there's enough women
who use these extracurricular activities
that put their relationships at risk as
a ruse for just going out to have fun
when in actuality they really want it
they really just want to hook up with
other guys there's nothing wrong with
women hooking up with a bunch of dudes
there's nothing wrong with that a lot of
guys say oh my god women are terrible
because i want to sleep around listen
man i've known a lot of promiscuous
females and most of them are actually
pretty cool
there are some that i really could not
stand but a lot of promiscuous women are
not bad people they're bad girlfriends
and wives but that does not make them
bad people i think we need to really i
think we need to really understand that
the the the sexual marketplace is devoid
of morality and it should be because
because when we're talking about natural
selection
we as humans we're we're we're the only
species on earth who appeared to have
the the the ability to reason on 30
different levels we get emotional when
we get cheated on we get emotional when
things happen lions and lionesses don't
get emotional when they see you know
simba smash and nala then smashing
another female line it just doesn't it
just doesn't work that way um and so i
think that i think a lot of men the
reason why they end up being the second
choice of their wives is because they
end up sort of bending the knee to the
almighty society oh my god i can't
believe you did x y and z men these days
are literally discouraged from their
they're discouraged from protecting
their relationships and that's why most
of them end in divorce and or infidelity
that's right like evasculation is not
only normalized it's encouraged oh yes i
mean people just see it as it's funny
you know yeah and then on the the flip
side it's like to recognize his
masculinity to appreciate his
masculinity to to understand and respect
his boundaries then that's seen as as
him being toxic and controlling so it's
okay
if we
try to if we publicly humiliate our men
um and disrespect them on the regular
whether we're ordering at a restaurant
or talking to our friends
um and just to say oh my god he can't
even make an egg you know like okay
there are jokes and then there is the
point to which you have you
have
characterized your husband as so useless
that now you believe it
um and so a lot of women end up taking
on these oh well i can't trust him to do
this he can't do that so let me take
over let me take over i somebody's got
to do it and the next thing you know
you're you describe your husband and
your brain as useless
and the truth is that you've just butted
him out of your entire relationship
well and a lot of girls don't realize
that the nagging is so deep like that's
men men love through respect right and
when you're just like that's how they
feel love and when you're disrespecting
a man that's that's saying you don't
love him basically
yes literally
a woman can't love a man she doesn't
respect and it it's it's weird because
when men and women are seeing their
wedding vows or when they're committing
to each other whatever the case may be
there are back in the day
just about every woman fully intended on
going through with their wedding vows
but these days it could not be more
different it's really just kind of lip
service just to kind of say what you
want to say and now we have people
rewriting their vows and
and the uh whoever is in charge of the
uh of the wedding
he sits there for 10 minutes and talks
about everything that the man needs to
do for her
that the husband needs to do for the
wife but then when it comes to the
wife's responsibility
now it's crickets that's that's just how
it is these days well and that's why you
see everyone asking women what they
bring to the table and it's crickets
yeah right right
it's interesting what the the question
what do you bring to the table should be
extended what can you offer me
that you have never given to another man
most women can't most women can't answer
that question because most women have
given their bodies to men they've given
them their time they've given them
children they've given they've given all
of these other men all of these things
but then they expect a man to give them
everything that we have to offer i think
we heard this on the sauce cast um it's
um it's meat it's uh what is it money
energy attention and time
when
women expect all of this money uh energy
attention and time for for what what for
them just being there
no no no no you've given what what you
are offering to me is something that
you've given to 474 other dudes no i
need to know what you bring i need it
474
whatever the case may be there are some
triple and quadruple digit hoes out here
running these streets and we will never
listen you will never know what help
most women probably don't even know what
their body counts are but the point is
is that dude 99 of women out there don't
bring anything to the table that they
haven't brought to the table and every
other relationship which is pta and i'm
not talking about the parent teachers
yeah i mean this is